in this case I don't think it works like
that because in your circumstance you
could lose weight but if someone slept
around they can't go back in the past
and not sleep around in it they're like
so so what you're doing is basically
passing judgment but you're kidding
yourself saying oh well
there's no Redemption what are you
talking about I was reading like I'm
sorry okay let's just let's just be here
wait
um so let's let's just we all know a
girl that's that's kind of rebranded
herself yeah
you meet them at University they all
start at University there was a hose in
their ends and then they come to UNI and
try and be wifey and the girl that was
wifey in ends comes to UNI and goes home
mad truth faster Asian Community because
the girls that were part of the Asian
Community like Indian girls they used to
go mad in uni you know why because they
were prisoners at home yeah yeah and
this is different and this is the
reality everybody wants the wishy-washy
and blur the lines but I think it's not
it's not wishy-washy bro I'm not saying
I'm not saying there's no such thing as
a whole and I'm not saying it's a good
thing I'm just saying that I think a lot
of a lot of the way we talk about it
sounds like it's unnecessarily negative
and judgmental for people who I'm I'm a
big fan of shaming when you can do
something about it
yeah
it's like well she can't change
she could stop sleeping with the whole
football team yeah if if I was advising
her I'd be like look
you might want to move
good news
and this guy's this question would you
rather have a girl that slept with 20 or
sometimes I'll say 10 depends on the day
but 10 20 dudes you don't know or three
you do know
most guys most guys and this is most
guys will pick the 10 or the 20 that
they don't know you know what if I don't
have to see them if I don't have to meet
them what like I don't know
okay okay yeah I'm gonna be dreaming
about those dudes and I'm not you said
I'm just saying if I was advising this
girl I'd be like look you gotta stop one
you gotta stop doing what you're doing
yeah you might know how to move cities
gonna have to yeah and and so I'm not
saying like you can ever come back like
she's still a hoe deep down but that's
that's what I would talk I understand so
you're talking about continuously being
on her yeah
do you think that she'll ever be able to
be a committed relationship if she slept
with someone like 50 people okay I'm
just saying if she if she came to me and
and was asking me for advice yes I
wouldn't advise a guy to date her like
if the guys were but I'm just saying
like I'm just saying she's looking for a
husband if she's saying you know I'm
really done and I'm really I I
personally think once a hoe always a hoe
papa will give no references
I won't be referring but if you said
what's the best way to come out on top
be like okay
she has a nice hair yeah she's
charismatic she's charismatic she's
popular
I hear what you're saying though like it
so you're talking about like trying the
continuous Behavior yeah but I but I
also wouldn't say to like make it super
hard like because you're still a hoe
deep down so you can't like the
born-again Virgin going to church thing
like if a guy's actually taking you
serious why are you gonna make him it
that hard for him to sleep with you if
you know what you are actually I was
speaking with my friend recently um and
um she is 30 something and um she's in a
relationship and she still hasn't slept
with her boyfriend that she's been with
for like three or four months he's
sleeping with somebody else but unless
she a virgin no but that's the thing and
I know and I and I um and I said to her
but why are you making him wait when I
know you've slept with guys after like a
week and she was like yeah but you know
I'm not doing that anymore I want you to
respect me I want him to respect me and
obviously he doesn't know her sexual
past so she's dumb though he's dumb
brother
no no no because the thing is if I was
to get out of my relationship for
example I know I wouldn't be able to
press them but yeah exactly
like I wouldn't have been able to sleep
with someone for a very long time even
if I start dating I reckon I would have
that rule of at least I don't know
either you're in an exception to the
rules but that's what I'm saying you
don't believe a girl so he might believe
her because she's been in a lot of
long-term relationships and then she
might say actually I have put it put it
put it this way from for me from my
experience as soon as you start talking
to a new girl she's never slept with no
one for the last six months all of them
every single every time you speak to a
new guy I haven't been with no one for
the last six months I haven't slept with
no one who are you talking to Bro
nowadays will tell you every guy
but I'm saying we're talking about
General you're talking about exceptions
to the rule the general consensus of
women will play PC
they're not going to tell you how it is
so okay you think they tell you exactly
in my experience the girls I'm meeting
these days will be like oh there's a cue
for me
wait okay
um what about you what do you think do
do women tell you
no 100 no maybe some some girls are
honest and proud our proud hoes but most
I've said eight percent they ain't gonna
tell you they'll be like six months old
I've slept with two guys three guys and
then multiply that by you know what I'm
saying I'm seeing someone that is such
an annoying thing to say I have a
question for the for the girls okay so
as women we all know we know we will
always know more than the men about
women's sexual history would you guys
agree with that 100 so so like when we
have friends like they'll tell us more
than their boyfriends know yeah so so we
know who gets wiped faster host hoes or
prudes
hoes hoes my friend well actually yeah
I've got friends that are always in
their marriage and actually second and
then second question and do their men
have any idea so no okay no no what
about no I honestly do think you find
like most of these like single 40 year
old women that like are like sad that
they're not wiped up and aside that they
don't have kids in that it's because
they were hoes like in their past and
they regret it so much and like that
goes back to the Brittany Renner thing I
was saying like it's really dangerous
for young women because they do end up
regretting it you think prudes get
whiffed up yeah you say fruits um you
said hoes you think hoes get wafed up
fast confidence okay what about you you
think hoes get wiped up faster me yeah
um I think it's something I don't well
out of my friends the ones that were
hoes when we were younger are married
the ones that weren't are married
because they've been very career driven
okay what do you think I think it's a
mixture I feel like I know certain
friends who are hoes hoes but their man
don't know so that's why they get
whiffed up but then I know certainly
improved to get no men at all so I feel
like it just depends how you present
yourself do the prudes present
themselves like hoes as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible